[Music]
this one's going to be a jk mystery
article because the um
they still don't know why this happened
but of course everybody in this room has
their own take and someone's got to be
right so me
[Laughter]
and it's funny because earlier this is
the one where you said a joke and it
made me think of this article because
it's pretty much what happened a man in
liverpool was standing outside of aldi's
supermarket when he was randomly
attacked by an unknown group of people
and stabbed repeatedly in the ass i made
a joke oh what oh yeah in the ass
in the ass i wonder if this is going to
be a sword man i wonder if there's one
of hannah's friends
liverpool oh
liverpool
why do people get ass stabbed in
liverpool why why in the ass so he's
literally standing outside the
supermarket and then this like he got
rushed by a group
because they're the ass bandits oh my
god well i guess yeah if it's a branding
thing
they gotta stay on brand all right so
that that's your take you think it's a
m.o i think there's a new
gang in town and they're called the rump
roasts the rump road
that's kind of fire you know where that
rock browse hey how do i get into the
rump roast how do i get in the game you
have to cut up a piece of hat
but now he's in
yeah you're going to chop off a pizza
ass and then we got to slow cook it we
we're gonna slow cook we're gonna slow
cooking so they're cannibals too it says
that um that happened in front of
horrified shoppers so this wasn't a
thing where they waited until no one was
around it was literally in perfect view
of everyone and then it just ran up and
they just got him in the butt and then
they ran away they're like why him it
was a it was a prank that's what it was
right a prank like it's a prank it's a
prank okay don't mind the blind is a
prank
he's alive yeah i mean it's you know
how's his ass
holy
swiss cheesy sit down he has to say the
inner tube that's why they sell leather
pants you know that what to protect you
because if he was wearing leather pants
he would have been protected leather is
knife proof like real leather yeah what
about pleather that's why they make me
throw
imagine
imagine how hard it is
because there's metal inside the boot
nah the leather parts the thick leather
thinking the silk is so smooth that the
knife will go not because chinese
ancient chinese warriors used silk
underneath their armor and they said
that the silk was pretty good to against
uh arrows yeah and how many of those
guys are alive
today that's what i [ __ ] thought
one guy well it was a thousand years ago
so they're all gonna be dead it would
have been alive if they had chosen
better armor
but they had a life expectancy of like
60 minutes how's it going what's your
take man no i don't know man part of me
wants to think like this dude is like
insulting like some lady's ass or
something like that and it was like oh
fruit of justice one of the little
sisters like oh you want to talk [ __ ]
about my sis
odd place
but maybe if you want you're trying to
he's that guy's trying to send a message
what would make you want to stab
somebody in the ass repeatedly
with other friends
yeah we'll support you by the way yeah
and they're down this is the squad this
is the squad you got okay let's go my
this is your ass
where are the rump roasts yeah yeah who
are we gonna stab and why oh you ain't
gotta tell me why
toy's our leader bro second shank what
are we going to do if they got a flat
ass it's like there's nothing to cut
because we do have to take it back to
prepare it for master chef and then we
puncture it
the people that are telling me that i'm
not vietnamese enough there you go
metaphorically you should be drinking a
minimum of eight gallons of nook mom
every day to be real vietnamese honestly
i already do that
do you guys normally have a built-in
skepticism when something happens to
someone and you ask them why would that
happen and they go i don't know yeah see
already it depends on the person it
depends on the person sometimes or if
especially if this is a repeated thing
that's what i'm starting to be like you
know yeah
i was like that was a good thing that's
a good squish because that's why that's
my face
i didn't realize that i started doing
things like subconsciously i feel like
in a work meeting trying to be a meme
and [ __ ] and then it's a really good
someone will say something stupid from
across the room and i'm like and then my
buddy will be like you're doing that
thing
you look at me like that all the time
right
yeah but if it's like if some [ __ ] if
someone is telling me like i don't know
why like my [ __ ] tires got flat again
or something like really
are you [ __ ] doing donuts at home
depot parking lots like what's going on
you know what's the dead giveaway when
someone is talking about work and they
go
she hates me what did you do
nothing i don't know
just exactly
you have to understand your reason
something yeah you don't think you were
wrong you didn't do your tps reports
or or people that say that they have no
friends and everybody else is always at
fault yeah yeah that's red flag as [ __ ]
right just like and they're just like
i'm like you don't have any other
friends you hang out with like no people
are just [ __ ] and they just like
can't like stand me or whatever i'm like
or something you're probably the [ __ ]
big red flag i bet the cop holding the
notepad just was like that the whole
time it was just like this is the first
time
you would do that yeah everybody are you
sure i like it when people first start
off with i was just doing blank yeah and
you know what's gonna come afterwards
it's like okay you can't justify your
assholeness man yeah
yeah yeah i was just playing around i
was just joking yeah yeah
i was just flashing these guys with my
ass
and i was saying [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
flashing my ass and then they said
oh why
i bet you can't stab me in the ass
you [ __ ] losers you [ __ ]
can you imagine with something that
plain
i bet you can't stab you oh you don't
think i could stab you in the butt right
no i bet you couldn't get over here and
then he's like oh whoa what's happening
why i don't know why they did that
well you kind of egged it on or maybe
maybe just a little bit
you just mooned three guys with knives
all right defend the guys how do we
defend the game though no no nothing
they're trying to ask the public they're
like wow why would this happen so that i
think that guy's out of lafayette the
police is perplexed uh yeah the police
just want someone to rat him out like if
you know this guy and you know he's a
dick tell us what he [ __ ] do you know
what i think it is gambling debts he
owes he's he owes all these guys money
and he has to pay him butt blood yeah
next he's gonna end up on squid game and
[ __ ] it's good because you want him
alive yeah because you know dead men
don't pay debts you know so but then how
do you hurt them yeah stabbing my ass
yeah i think you'll always think of them
and that and the glute bro stand up for
a sec bart oh we're about to get a
physiology lesson there's a lot of
musculature right here you know what i
mean so look if i oh my god
i don't think i could snap bart's ass
dude but hey there's a lot of meat you
know a lot of penetration so you'll be
fine thank you thank you
what's that that's a lesson you're
welcome you guys have you guys ever cut
your ass
no oh my god can someone say yes because
i don't want to be the only one
with toilet paper on the butthole
in one way like
i scraped my butt pretty hard on what um
on the faucet would you
clarify please
i was taking a nice bath okay and
sometimes on the faucet side
it's deeper than the other side so i was
chilling there and then when i got up
the faucet basically cheese grated my
[ __ ] butt cheek and i just when i
stood up
that happened to me before but on my
tailbone
i sat down on something cheeked up
enough to block i i wasn't i was in high
school i was like tailbone i was 115
pounds and i sat on something and went
straight into my my tailbone and i was
like joking around like yeah i'll be
fine
i couldn't i couldn't sit down
for a whole week bro i had to sit in the
inner tube i swear to god i had to like
buy an inner tube like a hemorrhoid
yeah i had to sit around with all the
time
oh [ __ ] you can't sit you can't sit
normal for a while yeah i got a bbl
pillow how did you cut your butt i mean
that's if you guys remember i told you a
story before it's it's pretty
embarrassing but like
um
years ago like i think i would remember
this
yeah um i was i was having sex with my
ex in the shower
oh
and i got lazy
because i don't normally like doing that
so i thought i could rest my ass on the
soap dish part that sticks out
i think i know so just kind of like you
know just
get a load off and so like
so she she's like kind of doing all the
work my ass is against this soap dish
thing and then it just shatters
and the porcelain just goes
in your butthole in my butt
in my butt mass like not in my cold
cheek or else
but the worst part is that it gave me um
okay
many worst parts you start bleeding
everywhere right the first worst part is
that when you bleed in the shower it
looks like [ __ ] freddy krueger like
the water and blood mixture just it
looks like i'm [ __ ] trying to dye
some cool shirts like it looks crazy a
lot of blood and
uh if you get a vertical cut on your ass
that sh
for months it would reopen up every time
i said oh
my god
yeah you're supposed to get it stitched
but i was too embarrassed to go in and
tell the story oh so you never went to
the doctor i got a stitch do you have an
ascar now i do yeah
just imagine it let me describe it can
you see it if you're wearing a thong
what
what
is it
good question i'm pretty sure it's on my
right i haven't thought about it in a
while you know look checked up on it but
it's on my right cheek and uh i was
hoping i could see it if we're in hawaii
but i guess if you're not wearing it's
gonna be a thong
but yeah it's it's it's a vertical cut
and uh anytime you sit because because i
wasn't getting it stitched and like
everyone's like get a [ __ ] stick
[ __ ] is bleeding yeah i would just
always have blood on my ass for like
months
so i would remember i can't sit so i
would try to like play this way like
chairs
oh my car would drive like this
oh my god dude you were miserable for a
while when you pooped
oh my god it's bad now yeah i just bleed
everywhere i got the reverse plank on
the toilet
it wasn't bart said i would just bleed
everywhere that's just
really you couldn't just hold on to the
cheek and then spread your cheeks no
yeah i would have you guys really want
to know i just put like tissue on it
because i know it's going to bleed why
did you try to squat and let that
solidify in that position so then when
you stood back up
it's already wrinkled
you know what i mean you want to have it
heal spread yeah i see what you mean oh
my gosh stand up it's already [ __ ]
you know i don't know because i started
out i just was trying to go back because
this is when i was still dancing too oh
and you danced with a rip butt i had to
and i didn't want to talk about it
that's the part that why were you so
ashamed can't talk about the real
problems
i
i didn't i kept it a secret the fact
that he kept the secret was the worst
thing because i'm like how big is the
kind of a macho man who was embarrassed
who was embarrassed about getting a
ripped butt yeah and it was during sex
it was when i was boring my actually
yeah that's pretty cool though you did
it during it was a sexual accident
because people are gonna ask well how'd
that even happen but then i look like an
idiot again because i got lazy
well during reverse cowgirl
i don't know it
that's it doesn't sound weird
that's what i was thinking i was like
wild bro i mean it's not literally like
you know it's like standing reverse what
do you mean doggy feel like i'm talking
snowboarding so she was [ __ ] happy
yeah no yeah she was it was i wasn't
doing anything
that's where the guilt lies is that
laziness and sex
if you weren't lazy you wouldn't have
that butt cut if i did the work she
would have the cut
i was gonna say was there a moment where
there's blood everywhere just like whose
blood is this there was and that's when
i lived with like six guys
oh yeah my
[ __ ]
none of them said anything about the
broken soap dispenser no i mean the soap
holder i told them i told them it broke
you gotta explain to guys every little
autopsy just go hey soap just broke yeah
what about the blood on the ceiling yeah
dude bro i am the [ __ ] wolf from like
uh pulp fiction the guy who comes in and
cleans the car that is me
as far as butt blood to bathtub they
can't even get a trace of dna harvey
keitel a blood blood bathtub